i know someone's gonna enjoy that but i
don't get to enjoy it it's officially
2020 and the new year is upon us so
everybody's looking to try out a new
diet a new challenge and i did exactly
that for the last 30 days with whole30
no added sugar no grains no legumes no
dairy no alcohol no measurements no msg
or sulfites and no fake junk food with
approved ingredients it's really a short
list but if you really dive in and look
at the the rules each one technically
eliminates whole food groups
and boy was it a challenge for me
[Music]
the original plan was to start whole30
immediately after my birthday which
falls on november 12th just turned 30 by
the way and that was a big occasion to
celebrate so i don't want to be
following any restrictive diets in that
moment you know what i'm saying little
sweets never hurt nobody cookies and
milkshake but then i began having some
serious second thoughts
but dr mike you always said elimination
diets are no good they can kill eating
disorders and even nutritional
deficiencies at times and now you're
gonna do it yourself and endorse no this
is not an endorsement
this is not an endorsement of whole30
for everybody it's not a universal
recommendation in fact there are very
few universal recommendations that
doctors give to their patients whole30
is something i wanted to try i wanted to
see how my body responded to it if you
want a video talking about the true pros
and cons from the scientific angle of
whole30 that's linked down below
[Music]
the rules of whole30 a lot of them make
sense to me and i was fine following
them but there were a few that i knew
were going to be problematic right off
the bat and those two are no grains and
no dairy i can cut out bread that's not
a problem i've done that before when i
was gluten sensitive in the past i've
overcome that but the fact that i have
to give up brown rice quinoa things that
i eat part of a healthy diet my sushi
that's if you know what i eat that's
like my go-to meal so i was going to be
suffering without having rice and then
to not have cheese cheese cheese it's
what makes the world go around it's like
my favorite thing even in salads like
you need to put a little blue cheese
crumble in there to make it taste good
so i knew right away that that was going
to be a problem what i tried to do was
to plan a little bit more thoroughly
figure out what places i can still eat
in but just make sure that my food was
still whole30 approved for example on a
work day all right my usual midday work
meal is chipotle and i initially thought
i couldn't have chipotle on whole30 but
boy was i wrong all i had to do was take
out the rice and beans and i'm good to
go oh and the cheese obviously
so what do i have in my bowl salad bowl
double the meat chicken mild salsa
guacamole and the fajita vegetables
sounds yummy
[Music]
boy did i make a mistake giving up
sweets during the sweetest time of the
year bro
i'm trying to start my first day at
whole30 and then what is this
what is this
and then
what is this
it's ridiculous in here holidays
birthdays retirements there were cakes
and chocolate bars everywhere part of
trying to give something up your success
depends on getting away from those
things i made sure that i didn't have
any sweets in my house so i couldn't
cheat but constantly being
met with sweets galore in the hospital
that was a serious challenge for me and
i was like oh my god am i gonna give in
but for some reason having those rules
made it a little bit easier because i
just deferred to the rules as opposed to
like no i really shouldn't
[Music]
boy i miss something big what holiday
falls from the middle of november to the
middle of december thanksgiving how'd i
not think this through and on top of it
i was invited to an amazing thanksgiving
greek dinner and if you've never had a
greek dinner
the whole dirty struggle is real out of
grief thank you i love you you agree
with
me
it's not like my sous vide cooking that
you saw not too long ago it's much much
better than that basically all i could
put on my plate was the turkey and some
peas because everything else had cheese
on it or some kind of grain and i was
just sitting there unhappily everyone
looked at me like i was crazy you know
that scene from my big fat greek wedding
what do you mean you don't eat no meat
what do you mean you don't eat no rice
oh it's okay we have cake i'm like no do
you know how bad i want to eat this
right now
[Music]
one of the rules of whole30 is that you
can't drink alcohol to me not a big deal
not a big drinker anyway i'll have a
glass of wine or drink here and there
for celebratory purposes but now
i went to miami for art basel if you
don't know what art basil is it's like a
fancy schmancy art event with a ton of
exhibits in miami great weather great
people everyone's happy people are
having drinks you've never been to miami
a big part of the celebration during art
basel is to go out at night i've never
really gone out to nightclubs without
having at least one drink it's not about
getting drunk for me just about you know
like having a drink and loosening up but
being out with like two chains on top of
you singing and i'm there just drinking
water everyone felt like i was a buzz
kill at this thing mike have a drink
with us you know cheers cheers and i
would be cheers in water and people
would get offended i was able to
withstand that but i could easily see
how if you're trying to follow whole30
the peer pressure can
really motivate someone to cheat
[Music]
i was moving i was grooving i was
starting to feel good on whole30 i was
even getting proud telling people like
oh no no rice for me just sashimi or
whatever it is i was eating but then
disaster struck again probably due to
poor planning but it was a true disaster
went to the gym a few times and my bench
started going down which makes no sense
normally like when i'm working out i'm
benching like 225 255 225 was becoming a
huge challenge for me when i stepped
onto the basketball court after one game
i felt like i was exhausted it made no
sense to me it's not because i turned
30. it's probably because i was under
eating my calories when you do an
elimination diet like whole30 it's very
easy to undereat calories this is
probably why a lot of people lose weight
but now myself being an athlete i needed
to plan for that i should have thought
more ahead to make sure that i can still
perform
on the court and in the gym
[Music]
once i threw in some extra calories
things improved a lot i was having less
cravings performing better in the gym
actually my body probably looked the
best that it's looked in some time
following this because i did a lot of
caloric restriction unintentionally and
then kept working out and then up my
protein just got back from the gym so i
need my little post workout meal
whole30 approved we got wild planet a
little grilled chicken oops i spilled
some i was even already so used to the
eating habits like of things i could and
couldn't eat that when i would go out to
eat with somebody they would get like an
awesome little bun cake or like some
rice something looks delicious i wasn't
even stressing it anymore like once you
get out of old habits and you develop
new ones it's not that big of a deal i
was actually feeling really good and
proud of myself that i was getting to
the end
[Music]
now when you hit your 30-day mark it's
not over you then enter the phase of
reintroduction of the foods one by one
to see how they would affect your body
because the whole premise of this is not
only to develop a better relationship
with foods but it's also to see if those
foods negatively affect your body this
is like the claim of whole30 that i'm
not a huge fan of it's not really
scientific like if you put in legumes on
the first day then two days later added
sugars and two days after that grains
like that's not scientific if we're
doing a proper elimination challenge in
the medical setting we do a 90-day
elimination we keep a strict log of
symptoms we then do a reintroduction one
at a time to see if and when symptoms
return i can put in legumes on day one
day two i can put in grains and then i
have symptoms on day six and it could be
two to any one of those it's not very
scientific because you don't know what's
happening there
[Music]
if you followed my previous 30 day
challenges you know that my digestive
system becomes an absolute mess i mean
bloating diarrhea whenever i make any
kind of drastic changes and believe me
this was a drastic change when i began
that reintroduction phase everything
went back to normal i mean yes i
included more vegetables in my diet but
by doing so everything returned back to
normal i started feeling good again i
just think that these major drastic
changes when you're already eating
healthy
probably aren't great for your
microbiome and your overall gut health
so i find that when i eat my normal diet
that's right for my body and my athletic
needs it works best for me but with more
vegetables something i noticed was that
i was struggling to get my fiber from my
meals because normally i would eat
things like black beans at least three
four times a week brown rice and when i
had to eliminate all those i had to find
replacement sources and yeah vegetables
fruits there's stuff in there i think if
i was to do it again i would probably
supplement with something just to make
sure i get enough fiber
[Music]
one of the main questions people asked
me when i was almost at the end of
whole30 was how did my body change well
i definitely saw some weight loss but
remember part of the rules are no
measurements i didn't weigh myself what
i did notice was that my clothes were
fitting a lot more loose my pants were a
little baggier even my watch started
sort of hanging on my hand maybe i was
losing muscle because i was under eating
calories but there's definitely ways you
can mitigate all of that depending on
what your goals are that's why my
recommendation is to never just do these
on a whim talk to a nutritionist a
registered dietitian a physician
somebody that can give you some guidance
on what you should be doing in fact my
whole gripe with whole30 is that it
really encourages people to do this on a
whim they're like oh if you're fatigued
try this it may help it's true it may
help especially if you're eating a ton
of junk food but what if you have a
vitamin d deficiency that you're not
aware of and then you do whole30 you
don't need dairy and that worsens your
vitamin d deficiency or your anemic or
something i mean there's so many reasons
why people can have symptoms that's
exactly the reason why you should be
evaluated before you start a drastic
elimination diet like this that's not
knocking whole30 that's just spitting
facts at the end of the day nutritional
advice should be individualized but it's
a very restrictive diet it can cause
some serious problems there's definitely
some research showing that there's some
crossover with eating disorders and most
of the time it's unnecessary i just feel
that there's other ways of getting
someone to eat healthy than to give them
a strict list of eight things to do and
eliminating some foods that i think are
otherwise healthy why would you
eliminate certain foods like black beans
that can be so healthy to the majority
of people
a lot of it doesn't make sense but look
if you want a challenge for yourself
like i did and you want to do it the
safe way make sure you talk to a
nutritionist or a doctor and you do it
the smart way if you want to see my
other 30 day challenges and a green tea
video click on this playlist right here
[Music]